[Musique]
le périple de Fatou a été long de
l'Afrique de l'Ouest à Niagara Falls en
passant par le chemin Roxane que notre
parcours c'est c'était très compliqué
depuis 9 mois elle attend avec
impatience son permis de travail sans ce
document impossible de commencer une
nouvelle vie nous sommes là on peut rien
faire en attendant les papiers Fatou
trouve un peu de soutien dans ce centre
de santé communautaire
ici la mère de famille peut recevoir des
soins de santé en français une prise en
charge nécessaire après son long trajet
vers le Canada on est choqué et surpris
ils viennent ici sont épuisés OK et puis
il s'expose au risque des maladies
contagieuses comme le choléra la
typhoïde les demandeurs d'asile représ
maintenant un tiers des passions du
docteur Mouy une pression sur le système
de santé qui n'est pas viable dit le
médecin avant l'arrivée de demandeurs
d'asile nous avions des listes d'attente
d'une année à deux années il est évident
que nous aurons besoin de plus de
ressources que nous on a on avait avant
[Musique]
réalise peu à peu l'ampleur du défi
migratoire pendant longtemps le chemin
Roxane a été un problème québécois avant
que des milliers de demandeurs d'asile
ne soient transportés à Niagara Falls
envoyer maintenant les trucs et on s'est
dit mais nous sommes à Toronto Fatou
était dans un des tous premiers autobus
qui ont fait le trajet du Québec vers
l'Ontario la mère de famille se souvient
encore de cette journée je me rappelle
j'avais ma fille
désolé
tu es là tu as cette peur dans le ventre
et en même temps tu te rappelles tout ce
que tu as enduré pour être là Fatou a
quitté l'Afrique de l'Ouest pour
échapper à un mariage forcé il y aura
fallu cinq longs mois pour arriver au
Canada voir des gens qui sont au fait
des cadavres
tu vois et tu ne peux rien faire il faut
que tu continues à tout croyais que ces
problèmes seraient derrière elle une
fois passé la frontière mais la
demandeuse d'asile fait maintenant face
à de nouveaux défis sans permis de
travail sa famille dépend entièrement de
l'aide sociale 1400 dollars par mois pas
assez pour trouver un logement permanent
Fatou et pourtant détentrice d'une
maîtrise en biochimie et son mari d'un
doctorat nous voulons être autonome on
ne veut pas juste rester ouvert les
détails et s'asseoir comme ça nous
sommes pas là aussi pour ça tu vois on
veut montrer qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut offrir merci d'être
venu bonne aventure au chudi connaît
bien Fatou depuis juillet il a accueilli
des dizaines de demandeurs d'asile comme
elle c'est comme comment dirais une
montagne une montagne qui est difficile
à escalader avec des ressources limitées
de francophones
enthousiasme est loin d'être généralisé
à Niagara Falls
par année je ne sais pas quel est le
plan du fédéral des plans le maire de
Niagara à quelques mois de la saison
estivale
nous attendons le retour des Américains
fait-il valoir en jugeant que la
capacité d'accueil de sa ville a été
atteinte oui
dans cette banque alimentaire on connaît
bien l'ampleur des besoins
[Musique]
les visées ont augmenté d'environ 85%
par rapport à l'an dernier à cause des
demandeurs d'asile mais surtout de
l'inflation
a besoin de bénévoles parmi eux des
demandeurs d'asile comme Fatou une façon
pour elle de s'occuper en attendant son
permis de travail si je suis à la maison
là je ne fais que penser je passe mon
temps à réfléchir aux problèmes
mais pour Fatou le bénévolat est aussi
une façon de redonner à sa communauté
d'accueil celle où elle veut construire
une nouvelle vie avec l'espoir que ces
nombreux sacrifices porteront fruits